and we have two speakers actually
there's gonna be a joint talk
one speaker has gone the whole pandemic
wearing a professional shirt up top
wearing crazier and crazier bike shorts
where no one can see uh apparently the
bike shorts have just gotten out of hand
craziness um
so
you know
yeah
all those crazy bike shorts and uh the
other speaker loves the reading and his
favorite book or book series or a book
i'm not sure is the savage detectives
please
everyone welcome brooke and ben we will
let you guess which one of us is wearing
crazy bike shorts but
uh my name is ben i'm a data scientist
my colleague and fellow presenter is
brooke fry she's a senior data scientist
we are both with new york city council
and we're here today to talk about data
as part of the legislative process
so the data team's mission is to promote
a data-driven approach
to the council's decision-making process
prior to this it's largely been a very
analytically informed process and we
wanted to
bring a new edge to it right so we split
our time between laws analysis and
visualization
in regards to laws mainly our
responsibility is legislative input to
acquire better data brooks going to talk
a little bit more about that later but
once we get good access to strong data
we can perform our analyses and we've
got a lot of folks with very strong
backgrounds who can do a very good job
of this and of course stronger analyses
means stronger legislation and stronger
policy
lastly in regards to visualization our
goal is always to make things clear and
comprehensible both for the council and
the public so we want to make sure we
spend a lot of time conveying our
results in ways that are useful
so i'm going to hand it over to brooke
she's going to talk a little more now
about the kinds of data we have access
to
yeah i'm just going to go over our most
common data sources and other creative
ways that we
employ to get information that we need
in order to investigate common problems
relevant to the city of new york
so getting data happens to be a large
part of our job or sourcing data um
we rely heavily on the open data portal
which came to be because of local law 11
of 2012 um more commonly known as the
open data law it mandates that any
information collected
by mayoral agencies that are relevant
information that's relevant to
the function of that agency must be made
public
and made public on a sort of searchable
um portal
so um
when
we when the data that we need is not on
that portal we'll sort of look to other
public data sources
we like to rely on
the census data
american community survey
for demographic information
we look to the 500 cities data portal
put out by the cdc to get at
modeled health metric data
and then we'll use landsat data or
satellite data to
get information about the environment
when our data is not on the information
superhighway
um proper will get a little clever
and we will um scrape data or we'll uh
we'll arrange data sharing agreements
with proprietary companies such as
safecraft we safecraft during the
pandemic to understand movement around
the city during the pandemic
and finally when we can't find it
anywhere we can't find the information
that we need anywhere we will rely on a
really big tool that we have
um the reporting bill tool and
reporting bills are what the city
council sort of works on and
[Music]
uses in order to get information from
the mayor side of things
relevant to their operations and so
mandates that the agencies report
metrics and those metrics get turned
into data sets and then
back to the beginning those data sets
end up on the open data portal
so a little bit more about the reporting
bill process um
it's a pretty um collaborative process
we sit down with city council
legislative staff to understand what the
issue is what the legal parameters are
and then what the best way to um to get
this information is so we turn this sort
of like issue or this sort of
investigative problem into a
quantitative question
um one thing that we are constantly
thinking about is spatiotemporal
granularity so how far down into the
data do we need to drill in order to get
the information necessary to answer the
question
um we always want you know the most sort
of granular information but we do have
to balance that with the privacy
concerns of the average individual we um
so we have to sort of do this
negotiation around like what is needed
and what is unnecessary
um and finally we
because it's a law and because it is
going to exist in perpetuity we want to
make sure that this law is future-proof
so we can't
um
can't specify certain technologies that
will eventually become obsolete we know
how fast that happens um so we can't you
know ask for data to be on like a cd-rom
and then
you know we'd still be getting data on
cd-roms and we just have
closets full of cd-roms which are
useless at this point i think
someone can argue with me about that
um so an example of a reporting bill is
the benchmarking energy reporting the
local law 84 2012
which um started with the question what
is the uh the landscape of energy used
by buildings in new york city so we know
that or we knew anecdotally sort of or
through some like despair research
projects that buildings are responsible
for about
70
that is a hard sort of
estimate to really get precise on but we
know that buildings are the lion's share
um
when it comes to producing greenhouse
gases
and so we wanted to know what kinds of
energy are being used and how can we
ultimately use this information to
reduce emissivity in a meaningful way in
new york city
so yes we needed more data we didn't
have this data at hand
so we wrote a law that mandated
buildings of a certain size
self-report their energy use each year
um the privacy concerns weren't that um
interesting with this law but we did
sort of have to think about the scope of
the bill we weren't really concerned
with an individual's use so like single
family homes we were more concerned with
these like sort of larger buildings that
have more complicated
energy issues
so we
focused on buildings that are 25 000
square feet or more
um they seem to be like the that was
like the right mark to get at sort of
the issue and then also to be able to
affect the issue
and so um
and then as far as making this future
proof well we just want to be able to
monitor this issue
over the years we want to make sure that
we can track if
buildings are doing better or worse
and when and where and why
[Music]
so um upon getting this data we were
able to do a little bit of investigation
and we wanted to sort of understand like
right like globally what is the
distribution of greenhouse gas
emissivity wide um this chart shows you
sort of chunked up into groups
and the
unit is on tons of carbon dioxide carbon
dioxide squared per square foot
and so we wanted to see you know like
who are the
what where are the poorest performers
and um where are the best performers and
is there any information we can get
based on um
based on the characteristics of those
buildings that would lead us to sort of
more
achievable um
and
far-reaching
greenhouse gas goals
so um we
looked at that data and and that data
sort of led to this larger and um more
comprehensive plan called the climate
mobilization act of 2019
where we used benchmarking data
to set um greenhouse gas
thresholds greenhouse gas
limits on certain buildings so we began
with the overall distribution we looked
at the worst performers the best
performers
and we thought about this goal that the
city has had for a while now that it
wants to reduce greenhouse gas emissions
by 80 by 2050. so how do we
make it so that these buildings have
sort of achievable targets and can reach
goals in a meaningful way
so we looked at um we
used actually boost in r to predict
um
[Music]
emissivity we
[Music]
pulled out the important features
and we looked at those important
features as a way to sort of group
buildings with like buildings so um the
first the most important thing that we
saw was that
the work that's being done in a building
is most predictive of how much
how how the amount of greenhouse gases
they are emitting
so
we we then grouped buildings with like
buildings
and we
um
defined thresholds so if a hospital
there's one hospital in queens that's
doing terribly but there's another
hospital in manhattan that's doing great
well it seems fair to say that this
queen's hospital can maybe do a little
bit better given that they're doing the
same kind of work the operation is very
similar
so
ultimately we decided that for the first
goal
we would look at the worst performers
the 20
at the tail end of the distribution and
we we want them to reduce to the 80th
percentile so we need to move them over
to the left
and then for the first goal so get those
really really sort of bad actors
essentially
doing better and then ultimately for the
next goal you need to get the whole
entire distribution except for maybe a
couple
um to get to the 20th uh percentile mark
so um
that's that's our sort of initiative or
our our whole entire strategy in getting
the city to get um to become a little
bit more energy efficient and less
reliant on
um
energy that produces
greenhouse gases so electrification of
the grid essentially
i'm gonna pass it to ben to talk about
pay equity a little bit another project
that we've worked on
yes so uh i guess in contrast to the
climate work that brook was just
discussing which ultimately led to
strong legislation pay equity is still
in an ongoing oversight phase
so
this is the result of local law 18 2019
which is another reporting bill that we
passed it took eight years to get it
through
and it provides the council with
unprecedented access
to information on paid disparities
allowing us to analyze them across
uh protected categories
this effort was led within the council
by uh council member combo who we can
see
right here thank you to her
it really provides us with the
opportunity to hold the city accountable
for correcting pay disparities where
they exist within the city workforce
part of the reason why it took so long
to get this data though
to relate back to what brook was
mentioning regarding reporting bills
it's very important to take into account
both privacy concerns and future
proofing so
we have ultimately managed to get this
through an api and that's finally how
we've gotten access to
the pii for
pretty much the entire city workforce
i'll just jump in and talk a little bit
about the model we chose and why we
chose it um
the data in its
the data the structure of the data has
some patterning um there's nesting that
occurs
um and
so we wanted to account for that as well
as factors outside of protected classes
which were
first and foremost interested in that
might affect um or might influence pay
so we had pay the log of the salary as
the outcome
um and gender race ethnicity and age but
then we had to control for many other
covariates um that might
impact pay
um
we
we just to make a note there because
this is sort of like a
bunch of disparate um data sets that
were sort of like put together
a lot of it um had
some or a lot of the columns had some
issues so we wanted to include education
level but there was way too much
missingness so we just couldn't
but regardless we ended up with a pretty
strong model um
we
accounted for the nesting that happens
within agencies so an agency might have
um
there might be an agency that has a
title that is across many different
agencies but that title might mean
something totally different across the
different agencies and so and then that
in and of itself might impact pay so we
wanted to um
account for that sort of
um
interness that happens
um so we had random effect on agency
random effects on agency and random
effects on
um agency and the title and the title
and i'll give it back to them
yeah so as a result of the mixed model
that brooke is discussing there we were
able to compare essentially the
unadjusted and adjusted it pays
according to the protected classes so at
the top of this page you'll see the
unadjusted pay is the raw comparison of
race ethnicity and gender
and at the bottom we have controlling
for length of service
civil service title code suffix and
level the agency and the managerial
status of the individual
now in the adjusted pay uh
you can kind of see
within a couple of cents
most of those pays are are
pretty close to uh one dollar
but in the unadjusted pay it's
significantly different than that and
that we believe is more or less due to
opportunity
access
so
if you have the same job and the same
experience you're going to get more or
less the same pay given that we like
brooke mentioned don't have all access
to factors like education
it may or may not explain some of those
cents on the dollar differences and so
that is something to look into in the
future but we know for sure that the
higher paying jobs are overwhelmingly
held by men over women and by white
people over people of color
just as an example at the bottom of this
screen this is uh basically fdny job
titles grouped by their median salaries
and women are uh in red very well
represented
in many of the uh
lower paying uh job positions within the
fdny
and increasingly less so as the pay
scales go up and ultimately at the very
top of that pay scale completely
unrepresented
so
while we don't know for sure at least
the the model that we have can't
necessarily speak to all these factors
undoubtedly historical inequalities
maternity education access poverty
factors are all
very much related to this now the good
news at least from our end
is that this will be an annual report
and so some of the questions that we
couldn't answer now or can't necessarily
see you know back into the past now we
can continue to examine moving forward
to continue to provide oversight in an
attempt to correct these trends
and i just want to mention that these
this pay equity analysis was specific to
the new york city workforce we know that
things sort of play out differently
elsewhere but because we have these
civil service titles that sort of track
people pretty tightly
um there is like a little bit more
equity
um when it comes to
you know job title and
um
promotions and
whatnot um
with the caveat that
you know women and people of color often
have less access to higher paying jobs
thank you
no problem
so um yeah sorry go for it no worries
uh just to talk about challenges right
we've talked about two examples where
we've had quite a lot of it success in
the council but we do also run into
ongoing issues one of them and really
the the main one that that leads to the
others is the proactive
nature of the work that we try and
complete versus the reactive political
cycle so inevitably the council being a
legislative and political body
uh we're sort of on on a sort of news
cycle within the city
and we do have to as a result sometimes
respond very quickly to
new things that come
uh or we have to work with data either
that doesn't
as of as of when it's important have the
level of granularity that we're looking
for or that might have high missingness
in both cases it's sort of like
a garbage in garbage out situation
so that can limit our effectiveness
when we're
on a tight cycle
totally um
but we're often successful and we should
focus on that i guess um and the reason
why we're successful is because we have
had support from leadership especially
the speaker of the city council corey
johnson has believed in since the
beginning
data-driven
legislative decision-making process and
sort of using data to inform us in all
ways
um we also find it
i think i mean i find it
really
um meaningful to engage with the larger
council staff and the public in general
and visualizations is the best way
to do that um just getting people to
understand and be sort of like
[Music]
kind of involved with the
process of
data analysis
you see a more sort of informed and
engaged
citizen and it's really fun to see that
process
um and we're also just you know our
backgrounds make us expert in reframing
legislative ideas or big ideas into
quantitative questions and sort of more
scientific um
science-based sort of approaches
um yeah so in summary we're just here
trying to make laws a little bit smarter
to improve the lives of new yorkers
and um thanks thanks for listening
thank you very much
uh that's
one of the things about this conference
is that it's government public sector
and we have all levels of government we
have federal we have state we have local
we have ngos so it's nice to see a local
government talk i know that new york has
been at the forefront of data analysis
for quite some time um it's been a nice
thing to see the city embrace data both
as a community in the city but also from
the government on down so thank you very
much both for the talk and for bringing
data to government
thank you thank you jared